[Music]
CGI helps filmmakers create brand-new
world from scratch
look we all romanticize practical
effects but some ideas are so big and so
bold that you need to pull out a green
screen
[Music]
the epic Avenger sequels supposedly
contained over 2900 CGI shots it's all
top-notch the movies most impressive
creation was the towering Thanos Josh
Brolin put on a motion capture suit to
portray the villain in many scenes he
warith a nose head attached to his own
head this is a common technique in
movies that way actors could actually
look the nose directly in the eyes when
addressing him
Jurassic Park was a CGI breakthrough in
1993 Jurassic world fallen Kingdom
attempted to carry on that mantle
while some scenes involved animatronics
other shots involve dinosaurs made
completely using visual effects on set
they had to get creative so actors could
still interact with creatures that
weren't actually right in front of them
in some scenes performers ran around
with the dinosaur head
like with a nose this allows actors to
more convincingly coexist with CGI
creations it might look funny on set but
after CGI the endo Raptor does not look
like a dino you want to mess with
Black Panther created a fictional
African country from scratch so most of
the time that you're looking at what
conduct you're really looking at a
soundstage in Atlanta Georgia those
stunning waterfall scenes looked very
different while in production
[Music]
it's hard to picture a world without
computer animated movies but Pixar
continued to prove this year why they're
the undisputed champion of the format
with Incredibles - Pixar is known for
its wide array of creatures from rats -
monsters - personified emotions The
Incredibles movies call for something
don't always see in their movies a full
cast of humans of course lots of detail
went into bringing each character to
life
[Music]
in the meg a cast that included Jason
Statham Rainn Wilson and Ruby Rose faced
off against a massive prehistoric shark
of course the shark was created entirely
with CGI so the actors had to pretend
they were fighting with a real shark in
some scenes they were actually
performing in front of a row of shipping
crates
the Star Wars movies use practical
effects whenever they can but sometimes
that doesn't always do the trick to play
the scene stealing Android L 337 CD
wallet bridge looked like a walking
green screen while she was on set the
big trailer moment from skyscraper
involved the rock leaping off a crane
and through the window of a giant
skyscraper while the rock can do just
about anything he didn't actually do
this wildly dangerous stunt so he leapt
in front of a green screen better safe
than sorry the visual effects and Mary
Poppins were highly innovative when it
was first released in 1964 the
long-awaited sequel will also mix
live-action with animation
the actors were clearly up for this
unique challenge the latest DC
installment brought an underwater
Kingdom to life like any movie with lots
of water-based scenes a lot of it was
shot in a water tank and other parts
were shot in the open ocean but many
underwater scenes were actually shot
against a blue screen backdrop but if
you're worried about authenticity
don't worry the cast still got soaked
you
[Music]